Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, it's great to see all of you today, church,
whether you're new to our church just checking us out
or whether you've been here for 50 years, uh,
this is a great opportunity we have every Sunday
to gather together to worship like this, especially on this,
uh, father's Day where we're thankful
for the godly men in our lives
who have made an eternal impact on us.
Uh, and especially though on days like this, we do look
to our perfect heavenly Father.
'cause I know some days like this can be hard.
And so if it is hard for you today, for whatever reason,
just remember to look to him
as our father in heaven, who he is.
Remember that well as now
that you've seen in the last few weeks and most summers.
And, and most other times in the year that we have sort
of these filling in the gaps kind of Sundays
where we're not doing a series,
we just pick up the next Psalm in our, uh, journey
through the Psalms one, one by one,
just whatever the next one is
until we eventually make our way through all 150 of them.
Key word eventually, right? We'll get there someday.
But last week, Psalm 67 was such a blessing, uh,
if you were a part of that here
or if you caught it online, it was such a blessing.
One that's been quite formative in my life over the years.
Something that I just pray that God would use to,
to bear good fruit, to lodge it deeply within us
and then bring us to a good place powerfully.
Uh, we pray that that would happen now.
Now, God has a funny way of keeping me humble
because, uh, as top as, as top of the mountain as
that one was last week as sweet a time it was felt so filled
with the spirit in that.
And, and then we come upon Psalm 68,
which as I was reading all week, nearly every commentator
said, this is the most difficult Psalm to interpret.
Like of all 150 of them,
this one's the hardest.
So I invite the worship leaders come back out
and we're gonna get no, no,
like seriously kind of thought about it.
Just let's skip it.
But seriously, that's the struggle we face today.
And it just happened to be VBS Week
where all of this is going on.
It was a great time, but,
but let listen, I, I think that struggle is also a blessing.
The fact that it doesn't just jump off the page like last
week, that it's not just an obvious,
it forces us to, to press into the Lord a little bit,
to dig a little deeper, to work at it, to move
beyond the surface.
So that's what we're gonna try to do today.
We're gonna ask God for his insight that he would teach us
through this challenge.
God, thank you. Thank you for your word.
Thank you for your spirit
that shows us what we need to know.
So we pray that you would do that.
Pray that you take this, that is a challenge
for various reasons and you would show us the beauty
of your word and how you work it all out.
Work it together for your glory, for our good,
and that you would open our eyes and our hearts to see
and understand what you want
to change us with today.
For your glory, we pray. Give us insight. Give us wisdom.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
So I've been studying Psalms for years now as we've walked
through this and, and as I've studied it recently,
this theme kept popping up of, of
what it was saying was the theme
of the entire book of Psalms.
I just happened to start catching that recently.
I don't know why I missed it before, but,
but if you had to sum up the entire book, the theme
of all 150 together,
it would be this God rules the world.
Like if you just had to take psalms as a whole, it said,
what is it about God rules it all
so he's worthy of worship and all the things
that these p songs are teaching.
But really that's the theme. God rules it all.
And so if we're trying to figure out the meaning
of the hardest psalm in the entire book,
that might be a good place to start just to see if
that's maybe what the meaning of it is.
And so does it work, is the question,
maybe it might not, but does it?
Well, it actually does. And so this psalm is first
and foremost reminding us of God's reign
as the king, R-E-I-G-N, his
rig, his rule.
In fact, it does. So in a similar way to
what we saw last week, we talked about chiasm
and the structure of a passage
and how we can find a tool that uses that and
and learn something from that.
And it's similar in this.
It's not exactly the same, but it's similar to the first
and the last sections kinda match.
And so it shows us there's a, a balancing there.
So you can see it on your notes there, either on your device
or in the paper that verses one through six
and verses 32 through 35
say very similar things about the reign of God, who he is,
what he's done, how he functions.
They they, they're very similar, not exact,
but they're similar in the way they say it.
So look at verses one through six, just to start
with Psalm 68.
Again, there's a heading usually in these
to the choir master a Psalm of David.
So we know David wrote this at some point, a song
that's meant to be sung.
Verse one, God shall arise, his enemies shall be scattered.
And those who hate him shall flee
before him as smoke is driven away.
So you shall drive them away as wax melts before fire.
So the wicked shall perish before God,
but the righteous shall be glad.
They shall exalt before God.
They shall be jubilant with joy, Sing
to God, sing praises to his name, lift up a song to him
who rides through the deserts.
His name is the Lord Yahweh exalt before him.
Father, the fatherless protector
of widows is God in his holy habitation,
God settles the solitary in a home,
he leads out the prisoners to prosperity,
but the rebellious dwell in a parched land.
So that's the first section.
Now look down at the end verses 32 through 35.
See the similarities here.
Oh, kingdoms of the earth sing to God, sing praises
to the Lord, sayah to him who rides in the heavens,
the ancient heavens.
Behold, he sends out his voice, his mighty voice
ascribe power to God whose majesty is over Israel,
whose power is in the skies.
Awesome is God from his sanctuary, the God of Israel.
He is the one who gives power and strength to his people.
Blessed be God.
So again, they're not the same, but you see similarities.
You see this idea of who he is,
what we should do in response, that he's the king
reigning over all things.
He's worthy of praise.
No one can stand against him
and one day all knees will bow before him.
That's the point of both sections.
And so the, the rest of the psalm, you'll see there's a lot
of blood, there's a lot of judgment,
there's a lot of that here.
And you even saw it here in this first section a little bit.
And what that could turn into is this feeling that
that God is something other than he really is.
But don't miss again, look at verses five
and six about this king over the universe.
Father of the fatherless, protector
of widows is God in his holy habitation.
He settles the solitary in a home,
he leads out the prisoners to prosperity.
But the rebellious dwell in a parched land.
See, don't think of God as some blood thirsty tyrant
when this is who he is.
A God of compassion, a god of care
that he has his eye on the vulnerable.
In fact, that kinda language is very similar to
what God predicted of the Messiah in Isaiah's prophecy.
This is Isaiah chapter 61.
Listen to this, the spirit of the Lord God is upon me.
That's just talking the Messiah
because the Lord has anointed me
to bring good news to the poor.
He has sent me to bind up the broken hearted,
to proclaim liberty to the captives, the opening
of the prison to those who are bound
to proclaim the year the Lord's favor, the day of vengeance
of our God to comfort all who mourn, to grant to those
who mourn in Zion,
to give them a beautiful headdress instead of ashes.
The oil of gladness instead of mourning the garment
of praise instead of a faint spirit
that they may be called oaks of righteousness, the planting
of the Lord that he may be glorified.
Maybe you're familiar with the scene
where Jesus walks into the synagogue in Luke four
and he just happens to pick up a scroll
and happens to read it in front of the people.
And what did he read? Isaiah 61.
That's where he was reading from.
And he says, this is happening right now.
I am that messiah that you were looking for
and this is what I came to do.
And so this psalm reminds us of God's rule that he
reigns over the world in righteousness
and judgment, yet also has love
and tenderness for his people,
especially the vulnerable his eyes on them.
And what the rest of this psalm is doing is it's giving
proof of that reign.
David was recounting the history of Israel,
what he believed God would also be in the years
to come forward from him.
He was just saying, this is who our God is.
But the problem we see with this psalm,
the problem every commentator has, everyone
who studied this has is how do we see a structure here?
Now we know poetry is not always gonna have an easy
structure, but there's gotta be something
that we can pick out.
How do we discern it here?
Well, this is we we do, we we read carefully.
Again, remember last week that little word ela,
you see it in a lot of the Psalms.
It was a musical interlude of some sort, a pause
to reflect as they were singing.
It was a measure of rest.
Whatever they were supposed to do
or they were praying it, they were supposed to pause
and consider What we see it here
in this psalm a number of times.
In fact, we can see it probably most likely used as a marker
to outline the major sections of the Psalm.
So you see it in this at the end of verse seven, at the end
of verse 19,
and at the end of verse 32, those are the,
what I'm considering, the first lines of the new sections.
Each time I made one little tweak.
You'll see that in a moment. But
what these section headers do is they kind
of mark off time in a way that they look back,
they look at the present and they look at the future.
And you'll see it kinda walking through this whole psalm.
There's a measure of past, present, future.
It starts with and ends with those sections
that are reminding us of God's reign.
But in between, there are these sections that deal
with God's work throughout history, things
that prove he is the king.
And you'll see it as we go through this.
And so we take this second section starting in verse seven,
remember that's where the end of that sayah is at the end of
that line, starting with verse seven down through verse 18.
What we see is that God proved his reign overall
from Egypt to Jerusalem.
That's this section. He's kind of looking back
David at this moment,
and he's writing, he's looking back to history of,
of God showing up from Egypt to Jerusalem
where he was, I'm not gonna read the whole section,
but it's a, it's basically a quick summary
of the Exodus narrative where God led his people out
of slavery through the wilderness.
God showed up to prove himself,
leading them out of Egypt.
And just show you verses seven
and eight at least shows us this.
So God, when you went out
before your people, when you march through the wilderness,
cellah, there's that marker, the earthquake,
the heavens poured down rain before God, the one of Sinai
before God, the God of Israel.
So there's, there's just a, a quick encapsulation
of the whole thing right there in a couple verses.
'cause Sinai was the mountain on which God met Moses,
remember God brought him up the mountain, gave him the law,
and he came back down and the whole thing
with the golden calf, all of that, but that's the symbol.
Sinai is the symbol of the exodus.
And so what he did then from
that point is he led them through the wilderness.
That was what we just saw, right? God provided for them.
They, they struggled as any
of us would through the wilderness.
They struggled through that.
But God provided, verse 10 says,
your flock found a dwelling in the wilderness you
provided for them.
So this is again, a picture of God bringing them out
of Egypt, bringing them to something.
In fact, it also alludes to the book of Judges, the battle
between Deborah and Barack against the forces of cera.
You go back and read Judges five about that,
but God was clearing out his enemies from the promised land.
That's all right here in these few verses,
even verse one of Psalm 68 alludes to that very thing
because verse one, this is interesting.
It quotes numbers 10 35,
and I know you all read numbers in your quiet time this
morning, but numbers 10 35 is where God told Moses
what they need to say as the Ark
of the covenant would leave the camp.
Listen to this, the Ark of the Covenant, the symbol
of God's presence among his people.
It was what God used to lead them to and and the wilderness.
This is what it says. Whenever the ark set out,
Moses said, arise.
Oh Lord, let your enemies be scattered
and let those who hate you flee before you.
Psalm 68, 1 said almost the exact same thing, right?
So this is a picture what we're seeing of, of
what God was doing to lead his people as the reigning king
to drive out his enemies from the promised land.
Psalm 68 is recounting that.
And so God proved himself from Mount Sinai, the Exodus
now here to Mount Zion, which is Jerusalem,
where God picked
to be the dwelling place that he would have.
And this is Psalm 68, verses 16 through 18.
Why do you look with hatred?
Oh, many peaked mountain at the Mount,
meaning other mountains at the Mount that God desired
for his abode, for his dwelling place.
Yes, where the Lord will dwell forever.
The chariots of God are twice 10,000
thousands upon thousands.
The Lord is among them. Sinai is now in the sanctuary.
You ascended on high leading a host
of captives in your train, receiving gifts from men even
among the rebellious that the Lord God may dwell there.
So again, notice David was recounting
how God proved his reign over all things from Egypt
to Mount Sinai through the wilderness
and now to Jerusalem
to his dwelling place.
God had marched them out of Egypt
and now he had marched up the hill to Mount Zion,
to his dwelling place where the temple was eventually
built by Solomon.
And so David's recounting that, yet that's not it, right?
The Psalm doesn't end at verse 18.
God's not just a past tense God.
Notice what else happens starting in verse 19.
Remember where that word sayah shows up the end of verse 19?
Look at these two verses verse 19, blessed be the Lord
who daily bears us up.
God is our salvation.
Sayah, our God is a God
of salvation and to God.
The Lord belonged deliverances from death.
So David is sitting here looking back.
He recounts all that God has done in the past.
But God is not just a past tense God.
He doesn't just rule back then for David,
God also rules day to day.
He ruled from Egypt to Jerusalem, got his people
where they needed to be, where David was at this moment,
yet he still rules every day.
Did you see what it said? Blessed be the Lord
who daily bears us up, carries us,
sustains us, lifts us.
We saw it in verse 35.
He is the one who gives power
and strength to his people, right?
This is David's picture of this God
who he knows, brought them out.
Now He says, God is the one who's with me.
He's bearing me us up.
But see what else this daily proof of God's reign brings.
He says, God is our salvation.
Our God is a God of salvation. Repeating it for emphasis.
God is a God of salvation.
Now our minds immediately go to eternal salvation.
And we know of course, yes, God is the God of salvation.
Christ is the only way. Yes, we get that.
But here in verse 20, here's what's interesting.
Those words for salvation
and for deliverance are actually plural words.
So what he's saying is that God is a God of salvations,
of deliverances, of escapes.
What does? What does he mean?
What he means is that our lives are in his hands.
Our daily lives are in God's hands. He is our security.
He is our fortress. He is our deliverer.
He is the one who gets us out of all kinds of things.
Here's the reality.
You and I have an enemy of our souls
who is hell bent on destroying us.
Peter calls him a a roaring lion, Satan,
who is trying to destroy us, prowling
around constantly on the attack, looking for ways
to destroy us, which is why second Thessalonians three,
three is such good news that the Lord is faithful.
He will establish you and guard you against the evil one.
So that's a reality that he's coming after us,
but we have a faithful God who is the one
who is holding us safe.
I can't remember where I read this,
but if, if we were allowed just a sliver
of a glimpse into the spiritual realm
to see what's constantly coming at us
and to see how much God is shielding us
from, we'll be overwhelmed.
If that's true, the enemy is always
after us constantly trying to destroy us.
That means there is this spiritual war happening,
the spiritual battle behind the scenes.
We can't see, if we just caught a glimpse of it,
we would be overwhelmed
because God is protecting us from so
Much.
And so I know I've, I say this all the time,
it seems like, but we might not,
probably won't understand what's happening
to us in the moment.
Like Why? Why did this happen?
God? And we try to figure it out.
We have all these thoughts
and we, we might not even for a while be able
to understand why.
And maybe not at all in our lives.
Well, we understand why this happened
or what's going on with this situation.
But what we know is that everything that comes our way
is filtered through the hands of
God.
We might not think it's good in the moment.
We might not have a picture of how God could use this
for his glory, but it is filtered.
He is protecting.
He has us surrounded
and he is the king reigning every day of our lives.
There's never a moment He's out of control.
There's never a moment. He's surprised.
There's never a moment where he has to rethink his plan
and come up with a new option.
And he daily, that's what it says, daily bears us up
as our God of salvation.
Again, though, that's not all
I did make an extra divide here in the Psalm at verse 21,
the Sayah came in verse 19,
but look at the first couple words of verse 21.
But God will strike the heads of his enemies.
Verse 22, the Lord said, I will bring them back.
I will bring them back.
And it it turns from 19 and 20, which is present.
It turns future. It's future tense, right?
He's beginning to look forward.
And so that's why the point here is
that God will prove his reign not only in Israel's history,
not only daily for his people,
but God will also prove his reign from glory to glory.
That phrase, glory to glory is used all over about the
future, about eternity.
And so he's talking future. God will do this.
God will do this. So he's seen past, he's seen present
and he's going to see future.
In fact, verse 24 talks about a procession
into the sanctuary.
Could have been when David brought God's arc
of the covenant into the tabernacle.
It could have been when Solomon came into the temple
a few years later.
But look carefully, verse 24 says, the procession
of my God, my king
into the sanctuary.
He's talking about when the Lord dwells in his house,
that's a future ring to it,
which culminates in verse 31 when all the nations will come.
So there's a measure of future idea, plus you have the fact.
This section leads into the last section.
We looked at it earlier, starting in verse 32, which seems
to be universal 'cause verse 32 says, oh, kingdoms
of the earth sing to God.
So there's a picture of eternity where all the nations,
not just Israel, not just David and Solomon
and that whole thing, all the nations, all the kingdoms.
Verse 34, remember he's majestic over Israel.
Yes, but his power is in the skies.
He is awesome from his sanctuary, which alludes
to it being in the sky.
So this is a picture of him in eternity,
Not just in a location in Jerusalem,
but in the throne sanctuary of eternity.
In fact, that's what we see at the end of Revelation
chapter 21, verses 22 through 26.
This is talking about the new heavens and new earth.
Listen to this, John saw no temple in that city
for its temple is the Lord God, the almighty
and the lamb dwelling place.
And the city has no need of sun or moon to shine on it.
For the glory of God gives it light. Its lamp is the lamb.
By its light will the nations walk.
The kings of the earth will bring their glory into it.
Its gates will never be shut by day, there'll be no night.
They will bring into it the glory
and the honor of the nations.
Does that not sound like Psalm 68?
You see the similarities where that,
that the other nations are gonna stretch their hands out
to God, the kingdoms of the earth, but sing praises to God.
His power is in the skies. His awesome from his sanctuary.
What this is saying to us is that he rules
and reigns from glory to glory.
He's reigned in the past. He reigns in the present,
and he reigns from glory to glory forever and ever.
Amen. Now, we could be done right
there And just by the look of you.
Some of you already are, okay?
But the problem is with our desire
to interpret the Bible faithfully
and to teach how to interpret the Bible faithfully.
This is a place where if we stopped right
there, we would miss something.
We, we've looked at the Psalm
and we could say, yeah, that's an accurate
presentation of the Psalm.
All of that, nothing's wrong with what I've said.
I'm not limiting. But one tool in our tool belt
is that we must interpret scripture with scripture,
especially ask the question,
does the New Testament say anything about
what we're reading here in the Old Testament?
Right? So this stands on its own. It's great, it's powerful.
We could preach that we're good.
In fact, the New Testament very clearly does in this case,
say something about what we've just read.
So turn with me now over to
Ephesians chapter four, all the way in the New Testament.
Ephesians chapter four, we're gonna see
how the Apostle Paul interpreted this psalm.
Always a good practice.
Look at how the New Testament uses it.
He wrote to the Ephesians, this letter, here's
what we're gonna add To all that we've seen.
That's good and right, God's reign in the past, present,
future, accurate, faithful, yes.
But what we're gonna add to that, what we've already seen,
what we're gonna add in verse in in Ephesians four,
we're gonna see is that Psalm 68 not only shows us of
what God's reign is
and is like, we're also gonna see that it points us
to Christ's victory.
Psalm 68 is actually pointing us forward
'cause in Ephesians four, in the context of Christian unity,
look at verses seven through 10.
But grace was given to each one of us according
to the measure of Christ's gift.
Therefore, it says, when he ascended on high,
he led a host of captives
and he gave gifts to men
in saying he ascended, what does it mean?
But that he had also descended into
the lower regions the earth.
He who descended is the one who also ascended far
above all the heavens that he might fill all things.
So do you see what Paul just did?
He took the crux of Psalm 68.
He took the basic measure and he applied it to Christ.
He tweaked the quote a little bit,
but as the Holy Spirit was leading him to write this letter
to the Ephesians that we now know his scripture, he he,
it led him to this interpretation that
what happened in Christ
Was far greater than what happened in Psalm 68.
That Psalm 68, what happened?
There was a prophecy of something greater to come
in the Messiah.
What's he talking about? What's greater about
what Jesus did than what happened in Jerusalem?
Well, first he says there's a greater,
there's a far greater ascension here.
What I'm talking about with Christ's a far greater ascension
than what happened back then.
'cause remember back in Psalm 68,
God's faithfulness hits a climax in his ascent
to Mount Zion in Jerusalem.
That was the whole progress from Egypt to Jerusalem, that
that was God entering his dwelling place.
That was the peak.
And now what that did is it held promise for their future.
The present saying God's gonna deliver us from our enemies.
God's gonna rescue us. God's gonna receive worship here at
this location in Jerusalem.
That was what it pointed back to.
But what Paul does here in Psalm, in Ephesians four,
is he sees Christ's ascension to the the Mount Zion
of God's right hand as a far greater ascension than
what happened in Jerusalem.
The greater triumph, the greater promise that all,
not just all of the opposing nations in the land, all
of the cosmic forces of evil standing against
God's people were defeated in the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus, which he proved by ascending back
to the throne of God That yes,
all those people needed
to be removed from the PO promised land.
Okay? And God ascends to Jerusalem.
I'm reigning from there, but Jesus says,
I'm taking all the enemies of God.
I'm putting them under my feet
and I'm ascending to that throne.
'cause Paul's already written about this in Ephesians,
just listen to this.
Ephesians one says,
he worked in Christ when he raised him from the dead,
seated him at his right hand in the heavenly places, far
above all rule and authority and power
and dominion above every name
that is named not only in this age,
but also in the one to come.
He put all things under his feet,
gave him his head over all things to the church,
which is his body.
The fullness of Him who fills all in all chapter two,
even when we were dead in our trespasses,
made us alive together with Christ by grace.
You've been saved and raised us up with him
and seeded us with him in the heavenly
places in Christ Jesus.
Chapter three. So that through the church,
the manifold wisdom of God might be now made known
to the rulers and authorities in the heavenly places.
So what Paul says is that Christ ascending to the throne
of God is proof
that he's triumphed over his enemies
over all the worldly powers
that could ever come against him.
Yeah, the ascension of the tabernacle to the
Mount Zion in Jerusalem was proof that God won.
Yes, but this, this,
this is a far greater ascension.
Is that not good news for us church, that God the Son,
it says here, Ephesians four, God, the Son descended
to the lower regions, the earth to be with us,
to take on flesh so that
he might defeat every other worldly
power and he's done it.
Colossians two 15, he's disarmed the rulers and authorities
and put them to open shame by triumphing over them in him,
the victory's been won.
And church, listen that that means we can walk in
hope because of that.
There is a hope that we can have.
We can walk in victory because of this.
Listen, if you're in Christ, Ephesians said, you're seated
with him already in the heavenly places, far
above all of those other things that come against us.
Lemme just think about that in his ascension.
We have ascended in his overcoming
we can overcome in his victory.
We have victory.
Like let's Just walk in that every day church.
But there's something else in Ephesians four, we can't miss.
See, what we normally think of a king doing
is merely receiving gifts
that the king is the center of everything
and all of it revolves to honor the king.
That's kind of what Psalm 68 indicated that
as the king ascended to Mount Zion, everything was supposed
to give, give, give to the king,
but the king of the universe doesn't need anything.
In fact, he's a good
and gracious king who instead gives us gifts.
This was the major tweak that Paul made from Psalm 68
to Ephesians chapter four, where in Ephesians four he said,
grace was given to each one of us according
to the measure of Christ's gift.
Therefore, it says, when he ascended on high, he led a host
of captives and he gave gifts to men.
In Psalm 68, it says, he received gifts. Here it says no.
He actually gave gifts instead of demanding gifts.
The good and gracious king gives gifts, not just land,
not just food, not just
protection, which are all good things.
No, this is the context of Ephesians four.
He's saying, I'm giving you things
that will give you unity within the church.
That's what his gifts are, for which he continues.
In verse 11, he gave the apostles, prophets, evangelists,
shepherds, and teachers to equip the saints for the work
of ministry, for building up the body of Christ
until we all attain to the unity of the faith, the knowledge
of the Son of God, mature manhood to the measure of stature,
of the fullness of Christ, so
that we may no longer be children tossed to
and fro by the waves carried about by every wind
of doctrine, by human cunning, craftiness,
and deceitful schemes.
Rather speaking the truth in love.
We are to grow up in every way into him
who is the head into Christ, from whom the whole body joined
and held together by every joint with which it is equipped,
when each part is working properly, makes the body grow
so it builds itself up in love.
So tie all this together as Christ
defeated the worldly powers
and from his lofty, newly won position
of Mount Zion at God's right hand,
he distributed gifts to God's people,
gifts that would foster unity, gifts
that would enable his people to become the mature man
that God created humanity to be,
to help us grow up.
He gave us gifts. And so listen, what
that means just basically is that we need you.
I need you. We need each other
that we cannot grow up into the maturity God wants us
to grow up into without each other,
without serving one another with the gifts he's given us.
So find yours. Find your place, serve
because I need you and you need each other.
Yet the greatest gift of all far
above teaching or mercy or service
or whatever gift that you have, far above any
of those things, the greatest gift is the one
that Peter preached about in Acts 2 38.
The gift of the Holy Spirit,
the gift that Acts 2 33 says Jesus, from that throne
of heaven poured out on his people.
So again, we're tying all this together.
The king ascended to the throne, victorious ruling,
and he starts to give gifts.
This is the main gift
that he taught about John 14, that he's gonna leave
and he's gonna send his Holy Spirit to those
who repent and believe.
That's how we are led.
Romans eight says, that's how we are gifted.
First Corinthians 12 says, that's
how we are changed in our character.
Galatians five says, God said, I'm gonna send my spirit,
which by the way, didn't happen in Psalm 68.
That's the difference. The Old Testament believers did not
have the Holy Spirit permanently inside them.
God's presence was dwelling in Jerusalem.
But now God's presence is dwelling inside of us
because what Psalm 68 does points us to Christ's victory.
He's the risen king, the risen, ascended Lord, overall,
giving gifts to everyone.
Every good and perfect gift to us that we need
for life and godliness.
He has given especially, especially the Holy Spirit.
That's the difference here.
That's how Paul in Psal in Ephesians four can take Psalm 68
and say, yes, that is right.
It's good, but here's how it really points us to the Lord.
Here's what it really means.
It means God's given us the gift,
the Holy Spirit that we need desperately.
That's how much this matters.
I know Psalm 68, you go home and read the whole thing later
and you're gonna be so confused.
I'm confused use. But this is how it matters
that our risen, triumphant, ascended king has granted
to us all things necessary for life and godliness forever.
That's how we can have confidence.
That's how we can have hope as we live out this life,
as we lean on him.
Listen, it's okay to be needy.
He created us to need him.
But hear this today,
he has also given you everything you need.
He's given me everything I need.
So as needy as we are, we lean on him and we have enough.